let's talk a little bit about Donald
Trump and in taxes and the tax plan okay
context the tax plan of Donald Trump so
far is a single sheet of paper with
something like a dozen bullet points on
it by the way with one of the weirdest
combinations of fonts I've seen in a
very very long time
there's no detail whatsoever if this was
a real plan each of the bullet points on
Donald Trump's quote tax plan would
require pages of explanation and
analysis and data on implementation and
even that would just be a summary of
really complex underlying details I'm
unsure if Donald Trump has ever had more
lies per minute than in the clip I'm
about to play for you I'm thinking of
that non State of the Union State of the
Union address that he gave where he gave
he stated about one lie per minute
listen to what Donald Trump says in this
clip with the highest tax nation in the
world our business taxes are through the
roof and we're not competitive and
companies are leaving ok so the reality
is none of that is true ok number one
even in terms of the rate the corporate
tax rate the u.s. is not the highest in
the world you've got Cameroon and Angola
Argentina Bangladesh been in Burundi
Gabon Pakistan Zambia they have the same
or higher tax rate on paper but that
doesn't matter because the key point and
we've talked about this Pat is the
effective tax rate on corporations it's
very low in the United States due to
deductions loopholes and offshoring what
does it matter that the corporate tax
rate is on paper 35% when companies can
pay no or actually pay negative
corporate taxes using all of the
offshoring techniques and loopholes etc
that have seen so many companies pay
nothing so right away Trump is just
lying that was nine seconds and I think
he told two lies there okay
let's continue on to the biggest
beneficiaries of Donald Trump's proposed
tax plan we are going to bring companies
back we're going to lower taxes and the
biggest beneficiaries are the small
companies and the biggest of all benefic
are middle-income people wrong the
biggest beneficiaries by percentage and
by dollar amount
are going to be the very rich period but
here's the real key part okay here's the
focus what about how Donald Trump's own
tax plan will influence the taxes that
he pays take a listen to this middle
class people who have been absolutely
hurt so your critics are going to say
well real estate companies like
president Trump's company will benefit
along with that middle cut so is this
waiting to make a turn or you don't
value a cut in the middle 439 six is
okay if I'm individually paying 35% I
will tell you that's more okay I'm going
to end up paying more then I pay right
now in taxes all right I will pay more
than I pay right now
the reason I'm going to pay more because
I lose all the deductions they have
deductions on top of deductions they
have hundreds and hundreds of papers
lemonade does and things that you'll
never heard of before
I have great accounting firms I'm sure
you do they come in when you're entitled
to a deduction for geese flying over
America you're entitled to this you're
entitled by the time they give you all
these stuff all of that stuff goes away
all of it goes away
other than charitable deductions which
we think is important to keep and
interest deductions which we think is
important to keep but all of this stuff
goes away so I predict I will probably
pay more than I'm paying right now the
one thing we did learn from Rachel
Maddow's making a huge deal out of the
two pages of Trump's 2005 taxes was that
most of the taxes Trump paid were
because of something called the
alternative minimum tax which Trump is
going to get rid of in this new tax plan
the rape game he's playing here is
irrelevant because most of trumps taxes
are paid because of the alternative
minimum tax so he can get rid of
deductions Pat like he says he will but
the truth is if you get rid of the AMT
his taxes go way down and just listening
to that interview it's almost as if he's
admitting that he should be paying more
in taxes and that it's unjust that the
richest of the rich pay such a small
rate and that rate should be higher
maybe not the 90% that it was under
Dwight the Eisenhower but anywhere up to
50% it should be rate and again we're
talking about a marginal tax rate that
doesn't down you pay 50% on all your
income just new income above a certain
amount
so this is this is a lie what Trump is
saying here but consider something else
Trump predicts he will probably pay more
it's his tax plan and he doesn't know
how it will affect him seriously Trump
supporters how much more do you need to
hear if now if you'd release the taxes
we could know for sure
the major revelation is that the plan is
not really a plan it's bullet points
each of which needs to be fleshed out to
really be called a plan if you took that
plan that single page to the
Congressional Budget Office and said
give us a cost analysis on this they
have very little to actually analyze and
I thought that Trump was such an
effective leader you'd think he'd be on
top of these certain things but it just
sounds as if he's delegating out all the
responsibilities and the people taking
over these legislative agendas are the
people in the establishment and please
do not fall for the simplicity is
objectively better thing okay
Republicans like to say simplicity is
key it was used with Obamacare when
Republicans would put a stack of two
thousand sheets of paper on a table next
to their lectern and say Obamacare is
bad because look at how many pages it is
and Sean Spicer tried this as well he
brought out a small stack of papers
versus a big stack and he basically said
the big stack is the Democrats the small
stack is our plan so our plan is better
merely because it's fewer pages simple
and complex regulations both can be good
or bad it depends on whether they're
thought-out or not on whether they're
debilitating or not the number of pages
is not relevant and the supposed small
government crowd is objectively always
thinking hey fewer pages means it's
definitely better that's not always the
case and you've got to break out of that
paradigm yeah it's really such a weak
argument and the fact that they wanted
to take over the whole health care
industry with a bill that was 66 pages
long it just goes to show that they
don't really know what they're doing
send me your thoughts about this I'm on
Reddit at dapat I'm sorry I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show we'll be back right
after this
the David Pakman show has a new sponsor
taga dab offers a range of affordable
flexible hosting packages including
dedicated
virtual private server and cloud server
options as well as custom server
solutions and UK colocation services
tailored to your business or project
they are very proud of their team of
expert hosting specialists who know
their stuff they make up their friendly
support team they give customers full
access to what they know and to their
services and 70% of their business comes
from repeat orders and recommendations
from existing customers which is really
a testament to the support that they are
giving their customers taga Deb
currently has an average Trustpilot
review rating of excellent at nine point
seven out of ten with more and more
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to cloud hosting
taga Deb is offering a ten-pound credit
to all new customers signing up to give
you a chance to try the service
regardless of where in the world you are
there in the UK you can be anywhere to
take advantage of the offer and support
the David Pakman show go to sign up taga
Deb comm / TDPS
that's signup dot ta ga da b.com slash T
DPS